wir kommen zu einer verfolgungsjagd
mitten in new york zwei autos liefern
sich einen erbitterten straßenkampf der
hintergrund offenbar ein raum mit
mehreren zehntausend dollar beutel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es sind szenen wie aus einem
computerspiel doch das hier ist realität
mitten in new york
[Applaus]
auf der second avenue rammt ein mercedes
einen toyota suv verfolgt ihn drängt ihn
mehrmals ab
das ende einer verfolgungsjagd
wie bild von der new yorker polizei
erfährt spielen sich diese szenen am
dritten september nachmittags ab um 16
uhr 40 geht ein notruf ein ein raub habe
stattgefunden
videos zeigen wie ein mann aus dem
mercedes steigt und bewaffnet mit einer
pistole versucht die scheibe des suvs
einzuschlagen
[Musik]
der fahrer steigt aus und ergibt sich
schließlich die räuber flüchten mit
einer erbeuteten tasche
was davor passiert bislang völlig unklar
aber offenbar wussten die täter ganz
genau was sie im auto des opfers finden
würden medienberichten zufolge könnten
in dem rucksack 20.000 dollar gewesen
sein die polizei spricht von einer
bislang unbekannten summe an bargeld
unglaubliche szenen die einige offene
fragen zurücklassen
auch wer die räuber sind denn die
konnten mitsamt der beute entkommen
[Musik]